♪♪
Narrator: THE CAN IS
FULL OF COMPRESSED GAS.
UNDER PRESSURE, IT'S LIQUID.
HIT THE NOZZLE,
AND IT SPRAYS OUT AS A GAS.
BUT WHAT ABOUT ITS POTENTIAL
FOR COMBUSTION CATASTROPHE?
TO FIND OUT, FIRST,
A FLAMMABILITY TEST.
SAFETY IS OFF.
Allie: PLAYING THE ROLE
OF OUR IGNITION SOURCE
WILL BE THIS HERE LIGHTER,
WHICH WILL BE LIT
FROM A SAFE DISTANCE
BY OUR HANDY-DANDY
INCINERATOR 8000
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
TRY NOT TO LOSE AN EYEBROW.
HEY.
IT'S TIME FOR US TO HAVE A TALK.
I KNOW I DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU
NOT TO TRY THIS AT HOME,
BUT THIS STORY INVOLVES
A PAPER SHREDDER
AND CANNED AIR, TWO THINGS
YOU FIND IN A LOT OF HOUSEHOLDS,
SO LET ME ADD ONE MORE BIT
OF DISCOURAGEMENT TO THIS MIX,
AND THAT IS THE PROPELLANT
OF THIS CAN.
IT'S GREAT FOR OUR OZONE.
IT DOESN'T DEPLETE IT, BUT WHEN
YOU SET THAT PROPELLANT ON FIRE,
IT CREATES A COUPLE OF
REALLY POISONOUS COMPOUNDS,
SO PLEASE DON'T
TRY THIS AT HOME.
Narrator: WITH EVERYONE
SAFELY IN POSITION,
IT'S TIME FOR IGNITION.
THIS IS CANNED-AIR
FLAMMABILITY TEST
IN THREE, TWO, ONE.
DID THIS LIGHT?
Narrator:
BUT THERE'S NO LIFTOFF.
-NOTHING!
-NADA.
OH, MAN.
OH, IT'S JUST PUTTING
THE FLAME OUT.
TRY IT AGAIN.
Narrator:
YEP, THE LIQUID PROPELLANT
IS VAPORIZING INTO GAS.
THE AIR IS JUST PUTTING
THE FLAME OUT.
Narrator: BUT TEAM SHREDDER HAS
AN IDEA TO ALTER THE MIX.
MAYBE IF WE FLIP IT
UPSIDE DOWN,
THEN IT WILL GET
A BETTER RESULT?
-OKAY, LET'S DO IT.
-YEAH.
WE'LL TRY IT.
LET'S GO TRY THAT.
TIME TO FLIP THIS
CAN UPSIDE DOWN.
OH!
Narrator: THE THEORY IS THAT
GRAVITY WILL PUSH MORE LIQUID
DOWN THROUGH THE NOZZLE,
ADDING MORE FUEL TO THE FIRE.
OKAY, THIS IS CANNED-AIR
FLAMMABILITY TEST,
UPSIDE-DOWN CAN,
IN THREE, TWO, ONE.
-OH!
-THERE!!
♪♪
-THERE WE GO!
-DO IT AGAIN!
WHOA!
AGAIN!
-THAT IS SO COOL!
-THAT IS REALLY COOL.
YEAH.
THAT WAS AWESOME.
SO CANNED AIR
IS FLAMMABLE.
-UPSIDE DOWN.
-WOW.
-NICE.
Narrator: SO BY INTENTIONALLY
MISUSING THEIR BUST OFF,
THE TEAM
HAS THE DESIRED OUTCOME.